[Musica]
matrice sostenibile e viaggiatrice negli
ultimi anni mi sono
dedicata a studiare un tema è un
prodotto un bene così semplice che
abbiamo a casa appunto l'acqua e quindi
mi sono chiesta l'acqua è democratica
e la mia risposta è stata No perché
viaggiato per il mondo mi sono resa
conto che un bene così comune semplice
disponibile ci passa aprire il rubinetto
di casa non lo è in tante parti del
mondo pensiamo all'Africa sanitaria
al Medio Oriente sono luoghi dove tutti
i giorni affronta così dette la
parmigianamento idrico Eppure l'acqua è
in alcuni paesi considerato un diritto
umano fondamentale ed è stato sancito
dall'organizzazione delle Nazioni Unite
come uno degli obiettivi dell'agenda
2030 Ecco ce ne sono scene imperi Eppure
scarseggia
pensiamo di conoscere la ma in realtà
non sappiamo tanto di lei perché per
comprendere davvero che cosa è questo
elemento per noi nella nostra vita
dobbiamo tornare alla tua Genesi quando
secondo quanto ci dà può sapere dalla
geochimica degli artigli anni fa la
crosta terrestre iniziò a raffreddarsi e
età presente nell'aria di ciò
condensarsi e accadere incessante come
pioggia e di lavando le rocce quindi i
suoi sani minerali ti depositò come gli
oceani primitivi appunto all'interno
delle depressioni e fu proprio dentro
questi oceani che nacque la prima
cellula vivente che evolvendoti arrivò
fino a noi quindi fino al Duomo quindi
noi iniziamo altro da un lembo di oceano
siamo fatti di acqua e ce lo ricordiamo
perché è all'interno della
canalizzazione del nostro sistema
linfatico e circolatorio che scorre per
più di 100.000 km
del nostro corpo ed è anche presente nel
sistema riproduttivo di tutti gli esseri
viventi perché gli anellini hanno
bisogno per riprodursi i rettili la
trasferiscono nel luogo e luogo ne ha
bisogno per il liquido amniotico nel
quale l'embrione può crescere Ecco la
Terra è rivestita e coperta per il 71%
da Acqua Ma di questa solo il 2,5% è
dolce e solo l'una l'intento è
disponibile per l'uomo quindi è
accessibile all'uomo
Ed è proprio Grazie all'acqua che i
primi insediamenti del luogo primitivo
Comunque i primi insediamenti istanziani
si sono diciamo così sono cresciuti sono
diventati civiltà intorno ai grandi
fiumi pensiamo al Nilo al Tigri Eufrate
il fiume Indo il fiume giallo e proprio
ritrova questi fiumi che sono nate le
prime civiltà idrauliche trainina anni
fa che hanno compreso l'importanza di
questo elemento hanno iniziato a
costruire dei Canali e dei bacini per
conservarla e per sfruttarla dopo le
tiene dei chiomi è dettata sicuramente
il diciamo la forza che ha spinto tra i
popoli a emigrare da una parte del mondo
all'altra se pensiamo agli affitti
popoli mongoli delle tette dell'Asia
piuttosto che i colonie europee
diciassettesimo e diciottesimo secolo
che si sono spostati verso le Americhe
proprio in cerca di nuovi terreni
fertili e di luoghi dove arrivare i
propri animali quindi vicino d'acqua ma
ancora oggi nella valle dell'ovo vivono
90.000 persone che vivono ancora come
l'uomo primitivo Comunque come l'uomo di
3.000 4.000 anni fa a contatto con la
natura e vivono delle piene del fiume
Quindi grazie a queste riescono a
coltivare i propri terreni e purtroppo
questi tipo Oli sono a rischio di
estinzione o perlomeno
rischiano di doversi spostare proprio
per un maxi progetto che è iniziato a
discendere
il fiume Homo e che purtroppo ha tolto
ha deviato il posto di questo fiume e ha
tolto la possibilità a questi popoli di
poter coltivare
Sicuramente nella religione Per noi è
stato un elemento fondamentale pensate
al battesimo no che ci che ci assorbe
dal peccato originale dell'islam viene
utilizzata per le produzioni prima che
fedeli si dechino nelle moschee
piuttosto che nel nazismo viene
utilizzata per augurare
invece i fedeli si bagnano
e spargono le cellule dei morti che
vengono creati proprio che le sponde del
fiume a baranasi perché questo li possa
assolvere dei peccati di possa liberare
dalle reincarnazioni successive Ma
l'acqua Ricordiamoci anche l'istruzione
perché il diluvio universale
secondo la Bibbia ma anche ad esempio il
Dio Nettuno che rappresenta nella
mitologia greca la distruzione delle
onde e del mare
è stata un elemento di grandissima
ispirazione nell'arte perché
tantissimi
scrittori filosofi e anche pittori la
nuova venerata come simbolo di purezza
di purificazione di armonia di bellezza
come ad esempio Giotto nel battesimo di
Cristo piuttosto che Monet oppure Van
Gogh nella notte stellata sul Reno la
Venere di Botticelli ma e soprattutto
nella musica dell'acqua è stata venerata
ed è stata celebrata in tutte le sue
forme dai musicisti antichi quindi dai
musicisti classici come dei Debussy e
Ravel fino ai moderni come De Andrè
addirittura ci sono musicisti che ne
hanno registrato il suono per poi
riprodurlo in pezzi nei ricami con mossi
proprio dal suono dell'acqua che scorre
o che gocciola e in Giappone viene
tuttora
utilizzata in alcune cerimonie e riti e
viene riprodotta da questo strumento che
appunto è uno strumento a corde che
riesce a riprodurre il rumore dell'acqua
il rumore dell'acqua è in onore
fondamentale del nostro cervello Perché
ascoltando questo rumore Ovvio non il
rumore della tempesta ma il rumore
dell'acqua che scorre o delle onde del
mare fa sì che il nostro cervello
produca onde alfa e teta che sono
benefiche per la nostra mente ammazzando
quindi il livello di stress di ansia e
aumentando la nostra serenità la nostra
connessione la nostra felicità Infatti
ci sono degli studi proprio scientifici
perché ci sono degli studiosi che hanno
dedicato la loro vita a studiare Questo
elemento e gli effetti del rumore sulla
nostra mente è stato scritto un libro
Blue Minds da scienziato americano
Wallace Nicols nel quale attraverso
strumenti epici e quindi esperimenti
fatti sulle persone ha proprio
dimostrato che la nostra vicinanza a
questo elemento leggermente più sicuri
più tranquilli e più felici e questo
secondo lui deriva dal fatto che noi
siamo fatti di acqua e arriviamo
dall'acqua sicuramente importante per i
nostri processi biologici corporei come
dicevo prima il 99% del nostro corpo il
fatto di molecole di acqua inteso il
70%, Questo vuol dire che noi veniamo
dall'acqua e siamo fatti di acqua ed è
per questo che probabilmente questo
rumore secondo lui ci fa così bene ma ci
fa anche bene al nostro corpo perché
l'idratazione consente al nostro
cervello di funzionare bene e
sicuramente anche a tutte le nostre
funzioni perché trasporta appunto i
nutrienti all'interno del
nostro sistema circolatorio e linfatico
quindi è ovvio che l'idratazione per noi
è importante e ci dice l'organizzazione
Mondiale della sanità che dobbiamo dire
almeno 8 litri 8 litri 8 bicchieri di
acqua al giorno 8 litri No perché 8
litri sono 90 gradi esattamente la
quantità di acqua che bevuta nello
stesso giorno da un uomo ci fa morire
quindi ho fatto un errore importante ma
l'elemento l'elemento acqua ha delle
caratteristiche chimiche fisiche uniche
ed è quello che ci spiega la più
importante nella nostra vita e del
nostro futuro perché non tutti
conosciamo la formula H2O e la formula
che ci insegnano alle scuole primarie e
sappiamo che faccia da due
atomi di idrogeno e damatomo di ossigeno
ma non tutti sanno che questa molecola
una particolarità perché i due attimi di
idrogeno hanno una carica positiva
mentre quello di ossigeno una carica
negativa rendendo questa molecola quindi
una calamita un dipolo e quindi
attraendoti le molecole le urne con le
altre crea una capacità aggregante che
voi Vedete poi nella forma delle gocce
di acqua e ci sembra di vedere una
pellicola a volte sugli carbonio sui
laghi dove le zanzare o una piuma si
possono appoggiare senza affondare ma
soprattutto la tua qualità più
importante dal punto di vista fisico e
proprio quella di riuscire a risalire
dal basso verso l'alto contradendo la
legge della fisica la legge di gravità
perché in presenza di piccoli collettori
come possono essere le nostre vere i
nostri capillari piuttosto che appunto
un albero che da le radici porta fino
alle foglie appunto è in grado di
risalire da Bacco verso verso l'alto e
anche l'unico liquido che
solidificandoci per il freddo aumenta di
volume e diminuisce l'identità questo fa
sì che sugli oceani il ghiaccio cozza
candeggiare e sotto la vita possa
continuare ad esistere
e molto interessante una uno degli Studi
sulla fisica più interessanti Secondo me
che è stato fatto in questo secolo ce ne
sono stati tanti anche di un italiano
Emilio del giudice che è morto pochi
anni fa ma è molto interessante lo
studio fatto da moto questo giapponese
anche lui è scomparso nello stesso anno
di contributi 14 che afferma che le
molecole di acqua viaggiano in classe
che sono delle unità di memoria e lui
dice che l'acqua viene sottoposta ai
nostri pensieri o parole positive come
amore gratitudine una volta che questa
acqua viene congelata e fotografata i
suoi cristalli saranno belli saranno
perfetti armoniosi Ma se noi la
sottoponiamo a delle Vibrazioni negative
come odio di istruzione morte questa
acqua avrà dei cristalli una volta
congelata deformi o addirittura
orripilanti e lui L'ha dimostrato
appunto facendo delle fotografie
Ovviamente è una teoria molto
affascinante e anche molto contestato
dal mondo scientifico
ma quello che oggi ci preoccupa sono i
dati perché Perché
voi sapete che quest'anno il 22 marzo
c'è stata la giornata mondiale
dell'acqua e i dati che sono stati
presentati sono davvero allarmanti Oggi
più di 2 miliardi di persone non hanno
accesso ai servizi igienici di base e
quindi all'acqua non potabile all'acqua
per appunto
lavarsi Oppure per le faccende di casa
più di 780 milioni di persone non hanno
accesso all'acqua potabile e oggi ancora
più di 200 bambini muoiono ogni giorno
sotto i 5 anni per malattie legate
all'acqua contaminata e nello stesso
tempo però nelle condutture idriche si
perde dal 30 al 50% di acqua e la stima
dell'uovo fatta quest'anno e che nel
2030 il fabbisogno di acqua supererà del
40% l'offerta
Quindi cosa facciamo sicuramente
l'innovazione ci può venire in aiuto
perché sono tecniche di più negli ultimi
anni Le innovazioni che vedo e che
vengono sviluppate e prototipi tecniche
soluzioni da Università di ricercatori
ma soprattutto da startup in tutto il
mondo che diciamo hanno come obiettivo
la riduzione degli sprechi la creazione
di uova acqua oppure il recupero delle
acque già utilizzate e tra questi
sicuramente abbiamo i nuovi sistemi di
irrigazione che addirittura riescono a
vedere con l'intelligenza artificiale il
fabbisogno di ogni singola pianta
attraverso i sistemi di depurazione che
riescono a decontaminare tutte l'acqua
da tutti contaminanti antiche e per
essere riutilizzati per uso domestico ma
anche industriale piuttosto che sistemi
di sanitizzazione ancora molto costosi
Ma che mano mano stanno sviluppando
delle tecniche sempre più avanzate ma
quello che mi ha affascinato di più è
proprio la macchina che produce l'acqua
dell'aria Ormai sono anni che startup da
Israele anche in Italia in Kenya in
altri paesi hanno sviluppato attraverso
dei principi di condensazione molto
avanzati questa tipologia di macchinari
che possono essere ovviamente collocati
laddove non esistono
produrre ma attraverso appunto la
condensazione dell'umidità dell'aria
alta in terreni desertici fino a 5.000
litri di acqua al giorno almeno di due
centesimi al litro proprio perché
utilizzano energie rinnovabili Ma poi
solo non basta ci vuole il nostro
contributo perché se oggi siamo in
questa situazione e sicuramente anche
per colpa dell'uomo ed è e dei propri
sprechi quindi Iniziamo da piccoli gesti
quotidiani chiudiamo il rubinetto
dell'acqua mentre ci laviamo i denti
possiamo risparmiare fino a 4 000 litri
di acqua all'anno
vi lascio con una bellissima frase dal
libro Oceano mare di Alessandro Baricco
Grazie a tutti e buona serata
[Musica]